let's try to add some details and we'll
add an aspect card which is the last
card okay
so we have glorious
treacherous
wish granting
and cloying
cloying means
clingy or it's like unpleasant I don't
remember
what exactly what that word means easy
to look it up
I've heard it used perhaps in the sense
of smell where something smells dead or
something but I don't think that's a
right let me just so yeah let's look it
up so we have the right time so the
definition of cloying is
disgusting or distasteful by reason of
excess
like cloying sweetness excessively sweet
or sentimental a cloying romantic comedy
her coinus grows cloying after a while
interesting
okay so it's
yeah just like too much
okay okay interesting
So Glorious
treacherous wish granting those are the
two that
well
glorious and treacherous are interesting
because as treacherous as we saw
Adolf Hitler
he saw what he was doing as glorious
like he was saving the world
so
the context and the point of view
with which you look at these things
like this automaton
could be treacherous and yet feel like
it's doing
the world a huge service
and it might be monstrous but the robot
may be programmed in such a way that it
can't see that what it's doing is evil
or wrong or ethically questionable or
that kind of thing so so those are both
very interesting and then wish granting
is fascinating
and
it's
interesting in part because of where
quantum physics is going these days
and an automaton's ability to
um
manufacture like Robbie the robot
could like
morbius would give him a sample of lead
and he'd say make us 600 pounds of lead
or 600 tons of lead and he just
manufactures it inside his body
one of the one of um Commander Adams is
crewmen
gives the robot a sample of whiskey and
the robot says yeah yes I can
manufacture this for you with 60 gallons
be sufficient and that the guy's like oh
yeah that would be great
and that's a
a bit of an old school example but if a
if an automaton is tapped into some sort
of manufacturing capability 3D printers
even the ability to Gene splice and
manufacture highly specific things to
order
it opens up a kind of a
Hal in 2001 type thing and obviously a
genie type thing but the capacity to
manifest something that was only an idea
through like state-of-the-art science
and enhanced capacity and access to uh
like if it if this robot was made by
a massive like manufacturing facility it
might have access to all of that
equipment even if it's stolen access
and like yes I could make that happen
so it's very open-ended in that way
and suggestive
but the one that jumps right out at me
is treacherous that like grabs me by the
throat
and wish granting is like
there's a lot of fun possibilities in
that it's very open-ended
and obviously in
any story that has wish granting in it
always has the caveat of
you know be careful what you wished for
like you wanted it so badly and now you
have to deal with it
but that's also I get tired of that
form of wish fulfillment stories and
it's also a kind of
don't you dare think big
type of
thing that Society does to people you
think big you're going to get it which
just is like crushing people down you're
worthless you're no good and I don't
like that and so I like to go the
opposite way of like you know dare to
think big explode the boundaries don't
let them tell you you're not allowed to
be great or be dynamic or
you know not just think outside the
envelope but disintegrate the envelope
so
it's interesting and it really could
these all except for cloying which
feels outside the context in a certain
way of these things but also
well I'm not a stranger to the word it's
not part of my normal lexicon it's not a
word that just comes to mind
and I think I've read it in novels where
you know soldiers are Marching through a
city and there's
dead bodies everywhere and they're
saying the cloying smell foulness filled
their nostrils or something like that
like overly sweet and weird and
so it the the few contexts that I have
for cloying
don't jump out at me at all like these
other three
I would say treacherous treacherous and
wish granting
are the ones that jump out at me the
most
okay do you feel we have enough of the
cards pulled uh to make a story or would
you like to pull an extra card
um to build more of the story around do
you feel like you have enough here if
you were to yeah I mean there's enough
here to build a story we're
absolutely building from scratch
because these are just raw elements
and you know you could build a a wacko
comedy or you could build a brutal
thriller or anything in between so it's
very open-ended you know there's a
there's a direction because these things
infer certain possibilities and Trigger
possibilities in my brain
um
so part of me thinks well another card
would be interesting but part of me
thinks there's so there's kind of
an embarrassment of riches right here
already and throwing another thing into
the mix might just be an unnecessary
complication
so I'm really not sure either way okay
well we can always pull a card later if